[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم اثر قرار السماح بحرق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف بغداد تطرد سفيره
السويد وتسحب القائمه بالاعمال في
ستوكهولم وتستنكر ما تصفها بالمواقف
السويديه المستفزه والسويد تقول ان اقتحام
سفاراتها في بغداد غير مقبول وتستدعي
السفيره العراقي لديها
اعلان روسيا انها ستعامل السفن المبحره
الى موانئ البحر الاسود في اوكرانيا على
انها عسكريه اوكرانيا ترد بانها ستعامل
السفن المتجهه الى روسيا في البحر الاسود
بالمثل من جهته جدد الاتحاد الاوروبي
عقوبته على روسيا وقال ان افعالها ستنتج
ازمه غذاء كبيره حول العالم
[موسيقى]
استشهاد فلسطين برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
واصابه اخرين في نابلس حيث اقتحم مئات
المستوطنين قبل يوسف في المنطقه الشرقيه
من المدينه في وقت اعتقلت فيه قوات
الاحتلال عددا من الفلسطينيين في انحاء
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه فجرا اليوم